[Musique]
je m'appelle marie pierre sirinelli je
suis responsable d'agencé bâtiment
durable chez cytale sita et c'est un peu
moins de soixante personnes qui tous les
jours cherchent à réduire l'empreinte
environnementale du bâtiment
[Musique]
je suis dominique renard brazy j'ai
fondé à plier en 2019 à fleyriat c'est
une une entreprise hébergés à skis cuba
l'incubateur de saint quentin en
yvelines et la mission daf les ja c'est
de simplifier le passage à l'économie
circulaire dans le bâtiment
[Musique]
la rencontre avec la fia c'est c'est un
réseau commun entre notre direction et
dominique blazy le partenariat s'est
fait assez simplement par par la
proximité puisque btp consult ans et a
et b tp diagnostics sont situés à saint
quentin comme comme à fria on a eu un
besoin qui est de développer un outil
pour une facilité
pour nous faciliter la vie dans le
travail du quotidien dans la réalisation
de diagnostics et eux mêmes des produits
équipements matériaux déchets
sita et et l'utilisateur de da kibo
l'assistant digitale du diagnostic le
diagnostiqueur va sur un sur un chantier
qui qui a pour but d'être des construit
en partie ou en totalité
et va pouvoir quantifier
la matière sortante a qui bossent c'est
un outil digital qui permet de
construire facilement les scénarios de
valorisation des déchets sur des
chantiers de démolition et de
déconstruction une fois les données
collectées il ya un travail de
compilation de données et d'analysé de
retranscription de cette donnée-là et de
définition des potentiels de
valorisation pour chaque matière
[Musique]
l'intérêt pour nous et de plusieurs
ordres techniquement un apport de
compétences sur l'outil est le concept
de mise en place d'un logiciel on est
vraiment dans l'innovation pour l'outil
digital à kibo on est dans l'innovation
dans la vitalisation du futur diagnostic
est là il est absolument nécessaire
d'avoir la proximité avec l'utilisateur
final puisque il faut que les
fonctionnalités répondent aux besoins
donc là on est vraiment dans le
développement agile le fait de passer
par une structure déportés qui est
focalisée sur sur le développement de
son outil
ça nous permet de
d'avancer plus rapidement l'utilisateur
réagi
à ce qu'on va lui proposer on a juste
c'est donnant-donnant dans le sens où
nous on va apporter de la ressource
humaine on va apporter de la data on va
apporter de
du principe utilisateurs et le besoin en
fait pour cet outil-là ce contact
vraiment très proches avec l'utilisateur
final permet d'être certain que les
fonctionnalités que l'on va proposer son
sont les bonnes donc ça ça permet
d'accélérer en fait les développements
il a justement du produit